welcome to this video playing teemo
funny car yeah I recently played and
lost against this person I played very
very nice game it was in one of my
livestreams check so let's see my my
sideline roses the and scotch maybe I
could have taken actually but okay it's
probably not the end of the world maybe
I should have taken hmmm pheonix tanks i
might play the C 5 stuff yeah that's an
interesting way to do it takes f6 that's
definitely okay for me but it's always
this nagging feeling that you're
somewhat weakened king could prove a
problem but here the bishop pair and the
bishop then on g7 should always be okay
let think a bit about what set up to
choose him d5 looks very normal but it
we can see 5 quite a bit especially when
the bishop is on g7 so maybe I'm I'm
sticking with this setup
okay he wants to go Bishop d3 I guess so
let's go here for Queen g6 as a possible
defense or queen age 6 an endgame is
definitely fine for me also Bishop f5 is
a move that can be prepared him ok so
I'm going back yeah an endgame is just
good for black with the bishop Pam
hmm okay I mean I have those slightly
weakened pawns trading one rook is
probably not a bad idea
hmm through could be 80 not what I want
just I need to make sure that is not
that is not invading on his seven I want
to want to keep one rock on the board
but I'm not quite sure how to do it this
and then Bishop e6 might be an idea to
check to make sure that this is
happening okay OIC just playing Mookie
one down and hopes to hang on maybe I
can take play play Bishop see one but
it's difficult to to definitely play for
win here with without rooks it's
difficult maybe here he cannot play
Bishop f5 or something as Bishop c4
rook trade Bishop c1b 3 i'm not sure i
mean that is of course bad of black but
can you win i want to keep a little bit
more on the board
be eight I don't know is he playing b3
at some point
okay also threatening Bishop f5 now
yep it was necessary so grabbing here
right and see why not before yeah that's
interesting now I can go see for I can
just retreat yeah retreating I guess
oops let's not blunder that rook no wow
not quite sure what I was thinking here
so mmm what to do pawn takes rook e5
maybe it's a bit of a shame as some i
was thinking i can go would be one
that's irritating okay
yeah of course that is now possible so
let's check how to do this
Sharon's difficult difficult i can take
a five rook c5a 40 k 5 i'm not keeping
this hmm yeah let's check can I go
somewhere else you should eat six Roxy 5
okay that's maybe not enough to win but
I need to play at some point you cannot
wait all day check
check is a bit of a bit of a problem
there look the rat I'm morning can do
this okay that's interesting actually
Bishop g7 takes and c3 it's interesting
so we're not blocking the fourth-ranked
en route g4 was surprising
mmm musical ugh i Luke a eight or
something that just loses time check
check check yeah I can take this but I
think I rather push pawns check Bishop
g5 huh look f2 it's not so clear
actually check hmm what is what the heck
I don't know what is happening here
check white forfeits on time ah anyway I
was a murky game yeah well here what am
I thought what is what went wrong here
looking for here rookie too I just took
that before yeah the droopy five move
yeah it was really a problem I should
just go to eat six I really had the Viet
hallucination here that I would have
this changes just crazy are you just a
crazy idea don't know why what I was
thinking them otherwise I never would
have played Bishop g5 yeah this is this
or that sets but that's bad this is have
pointed out by the computer
that's a clear violation of candidate
move principal what I did here not
considering that move it's just wrong I
want to keep the bishop on the board
it's just that I didn't see that and
then I ultimately went here guys
probably chan and in the drawer however
he played it in a very strange way check
losing tons of time giving me check many
opportunities check a for the only thing
what what happened here that I had this
possible this was bad have to go to him
or this booth this move that is much
stronger now we cannot stop the porn
yeah here all of a sudden has the porn
stopped with Bishop g5 coming yeah I was
mostly just playing James I didn't
really didn't really attack yeah here
it's a draw but I one on time yeah we
had game thanks for watching